christopher benson what is death of
innocence about
death of innocence is the story of mamie
till mobley and her son
emmett till at its heart it is a mother
and son
story and it's one that takes a horribly
tragic turn
but at the same time it's a story of a
mother's journey
the journey for redemption the journey
to
to find justice in the the horrible
brutal murder of her son
emmett till was 14 years old in 1955
when he traveled from chicago his
chicago home to
the mississippi delta to spend a couple
of weeks
with relatives this was going to be the
adventure of a lifetime for a kid who is
so
full of energy and life the wide open
spaces of the delta and all the
the wonderful adventures he had heard
about within a few days of his arrival
there was an incident that occurred at a
store in money mississippi
a few days after that he was kidnapped
by
white racist in the middle of the night
and
brutalized over the course of several
hours his body was found
several days after that in the
tallahatchie river
and this story really would have ended
at that point as so many other lynchings
had uh had ended uh throughout
throughout history
except for the courage of his mother and
several key decisions that she made
that kept this story alive and shared it
with the entire country
how did you get involved in the story
well i was introduced to
mamie to a mobley by a mutual friend i
had grown up knowing something about the
story
i was a journalist and as any journalist
i was inquisitive i wanted to know
something about
her i just wanted to meet her she's an
icon and
so in the course of our discussion at
her house
she just blurted out i want to write a
book
i want to write a book and i had done a
novel already and my friend knew that
and he said well if you want to write a
book
maybe you should talk to this guy he
writes books and that's how it started
this was june 2002
and within a month we were talking
seriously about her story
and even before we completed all the
legal things that you have to do
we had we had started working on it in
earnest and um
six months later she had died and
thankfully we had covered the story and
were able to move forward with a book
that
had meant so much to her over the course
of nearly 50 years
why did the name emmett till mean
something to you
well i was 10 years old when i first saw
the the picture
of emmett till the famous picture that
was published
in a number of of periodicals starting
with jet magazine
they carried it national and then the
chicago defender
the the picture of the brutalized body
of emmett till
was was publicized around the country
and
i think it left an impression on me at
10 years old i was horrified
i mean i was 10 he was 14. you know
he was so close to my age that it
it it occurred to me that something that
had happened that was so horrible to
this kid could happen to me
and in my 10 year old consciousness what
i saw was that this
this child had been brutalized had been
murdered because he was black
and that there were people out there who
could hate me just because i was black
and hurt me
so in a way the the murderers of emmett
till not only
hurt him his mother and so many people
who are close to him but
they victimize so many other people as
well i mean looking at that picture
has been something of a rite of passage
for so many black kids over the course
of a couple of generations
it certainly affected my life it
horrified me in a way it stripped away
the protection of my childhood
where did you live i lived in chicago
and he was from chicago so i felt a
commonality there
well we're how old are you today i'm 50.
and what were your circumstances growing
up
well you know we had a difficult uh
set of circumstances my mother was
raising us by herself and she had to
work so
um you know we we learned something
about what it was like to have to really
work hard
to to succeed and it wasn't
unlike the experience that emmett had
with his mother who for many years was
you know was the only parent he knew now
before i show the picture
for someone hasn't seen it describe what
we're going to see
what where was this picture taken and
approximately what date
okay emmett's body was returned to
chicago
on the 2nd of september 1955
and his mother as i said make several
critical decisions one was to insist
that his body be returned to chicago
uh mississippi authorities wanted his
body buried immediately in mississippi
to i guess put an end to this this story
she insisted that he'd be returned so
that was the first critical decision she
they moved heaven and earth to
uh to get his body back it came under
lock and seal
from the state of mississippi the the
box was was sealed
and there were orders not to open the
box she insisted that the box be opened
because she wanted to look at her son
one more time before she buried him
so that was the second critical decision
and then in
the the the course of looking at the
body she decided
that there should be an open casket
funeral that the world should see
the horrible face of race hatred on what
had been the beautiful face of her son
so the picture that that we included in
the book is a picture that was shot
of of emmett in the casket by
jet magazine and by the chicago defender
that was
was shared with readers around the
country and what it shows is the
condition that emmett was returned to
his mother in
after being in the tallahatchie river
for several days he was horribly
disfigured he was brutalized and she in
a very painful
way describes what she saw in the book
but the picture of course speaks to that
as well
at the time who published this picture
it was published in jet magazine and it
was also published in the chicago
defender and i think other publications
picked it up after that
and since that time as you went through
the research on this
uh how often did you find it well it's
it's
on the web uh it's you can look at it
online
other publications haven't shown this
precise picture
some have shown a picture of emmett in
the casket from
at a distance and we have that picture
as well from the balcony of the
roberts temple church of god and christ
where his funeral was held
so there are different angles on the the
uh the casket
and you say in the book that they had
plexiglass around the casket yes
it was glass and clothes and how many
people walked by this casket it was
reported that
that at least a hundred thousand people
walk by the casket in chicago
mother mobley made a decision after
viewing his body
that she wanted to let him lie in state
for four days and he did and during the
course of the four days
at least a hundred thousand people filed
by and they were visibly moved i mean
i've seen a documentary
since then and you see the looks on the
faces of the people who are about to
enter
you see the reaction as they leave
and as mother mobley writes every
fifth person needed assistance just to
get out of the church
people were fainting people were crying
they were visibly moved at the sight of
of of his body so the picture is on the
screen
at this stage he's how old he's 14 he
had just made 14 as a matter of fact he
was
murdered in august of 1955 and his
birthday is in july
so in july 55 you just turned 14. now
what his mother describes
as seeing at the time is not quite what
we're seeing in this picture
right he was um he was brought back to
chicago by a.a rainer funeral home
in in in the city and
even though she wanted emmett's body to
be viewed
untouched she wanted the world to see
what she had seen
the funeral director there did do
something to at least try to prepare him
for for viewing but what you see is is
the best that they could do apparently
what impact did this have well as i said
people were horrified i think that
what you see on the faces of the people
who are about to enter the church is
is a resolve in some cases you see anger
you see great pain
but you see a resolve it's as if you
know people are saying
okay this is where we draw the line and
from what i understand and what she
writes about in the book
that she heard from so many people is
that this is the
single event that energized them that
activated so many people to become
involved in the civil rights movement
and as we know in 1955
the modern civil rights movement was
just really taking hold this was a year
after the brown versus board of
education decision and the summer
uh that the second part of that decision
came down
so people were ready to uh to take a
stand as a result of seeing emmett's
body
they said this is as bad as it can
possibly get and we're determined not to
let it get any worse than this
so it energized an entire movement
according to the people who participated
rosa parks would later tell mother
mobley
when they became good friends that you
know she was thinking about a good many
things when she decided not to give up
her seat on a bus in montgomery only
three months
after the trial of emmett's murderers
she said she was thinking about a good
many things but she was thinking about
emmett till as well and she couldn't be
moved
and so many people have said that they
were energized by this and became
involved there were many people who were
who were in its age at the time of his
murder who came of
age at the peak of the civil rights
movement as we know the civil rights
movement is characterized by
by the youth by the young people who
participated in the
sit-ins and the freedom rides in the law
was a killer ever found
the yes the two people were put on trial
as i say an incident occurred
at a store in money mississippi we're
not entirely clear on what happened
but um emmitt and some friends and some
cousins were at the store
what's the name of the store it's
brian's grocery and meat market in money
mississippi
where is money money is in the
mississippi delta and emmett was staying
near the the town and and you call it a
town but it's really as somebody said a
wide place in the road it was a
uh what we might call now a commercial
strip but people live
near uh the city at the town and and uh
image relatives live nearby if you're
flying to memphis and i know
folks did to get their how far is it
down i-55 to get there
it's from what i understand about an
hour and a half two hours
you ever been there no no i wanted to go
i wanted to go
um in september of 2002 but we were
working so hard on the book at that time
that i didn't have a chance to go i
wanted to go at that time because
he was murdered in august the trial
occurred
in uh september and i wanted to be there
somewhere in that period to experience
what it must have been like
for for emmett to be there at that time
and for his mother to go down to testify
at the trial
it didn't work out then after she passed
i was invited to come down again and at
that point i decided i wouldn't
i'd wait until after the book was done
because i didn't want my perception at
that point
to uh color the uh the portrayal that we
were that we were putting together for
the book it had to be her story it had
to be her words but
in answer to your question there was a
trial
the the killers were apprehended
and they confessed right away to the
county sheriff that they had
taken emmett from the the home where he
was staying at two o'clock in the
morning
they said they had come in they had
taken them away and they
wanted to identify him as the person who
had done whatever had happened at the
store
and they said he was not the right kid
so they let him go and they let him walk
the three miles
from money back to the the
farm home where he was staying so they
confessed to that much of it but
they later confessed after they were
acquitted they later confessed to the
killing itself
they confessed in great detail to a
journalist who wrote a story a famous
story now for look magazine
they didn't implicate any other people
but there are a number of people who
have uh
said since then that there were at least
seven maybe ten people who were involved
in this
uh this killing the abduction the
cover-up
but there was a trial uh roy bryant
and j.w milam his half-brother were put
on trial for the murder of emmett till
and this picture right here which one's
which
to my left is roy bryant and the person
in the middle is his half brother j.w
milam
roy bryant owned the store with his wife
bryant's
grocery and meat market and on the day
emmett and his friends and cousins
visited that
that store within just a few days of
arriving
in mississippi um
he uh roy bryant was not there his wife
was
and something happened at the store that
obviously changed the course of of
events in history
uh it was reported that there was a
whistle
and there have been people who have said
well emmett was actually whistling at a
checker move
on the porch just outside he was a
checkered player and there was always a
game going on on the porch outside
he saw a bold move and he whistled at it
that was one version of the story
another is that he whistled at the woman
at
carolyn bryant the wife of roy bryant as
a prank
never knowing what that would have meant
in the mississippi delta in 1955
and the other version of the story is
that he had a terrible stutter
and uh he had had polio when he was
about five years old and
while he recovered the full use of his
legs he did have some muscle damage that
affected his speech
so he had a stutter that his mother
tried to help him work through
she did it in a number of ways one of
which was to
get him to stop steady his breathing by
whistling
and there was at least one cousin who
was there at the time who told a
reporter that when he
talked he sometimes made a whistling
sound
and so maybe till mobley
went to her grave believing that that's
what happened
that in an effort to describe to his
friends what he had bought in the store
two cents worth of bubble gum that he
had gotten stuck on the word
whistled to get his to work his way
through it and
that carolyn bryan was bryant was
offended by it
and everything else unfolded from there
and it's a horrible thing for a mother
to
to consider that the one thing that she
taught her son in the hopes that he
would have a better life me and the end
of cost in his life
it was a terrible attention for her to
to carry with her forever
on page 185 when you have carolyn bryant
recounting her story
you say when she held her hand out for
the money
she claimed that he grabbed her arm and
spoke to her quote
how about a date baby unquote she said
she broke free and that he came around
and grabbed her by the waist and spoke
again
quote what's the matter baby can't you
take it i've been with white women
before unquote
uh you you spent a lot of time leading
up to that point describing what kind of
a
young man he was right was there
anything in his past
that would lead anyone to believe he
would say things like that
no not according to what his mother had
said out and then you know as a
journalist i was curious about what
other people might say as well so i
talked to people who were there at the
time
not that i wanted to question what she
said about the story but because i was
curious and i wanted to make sure there
were no credibility problems and going
forward with
uh with the the book and there were
people who were there i talked to them
cousins
and and friends and they said he wasn't
in the store long enough to have done
any of that
one cousin went into the store and made
a purchase
he was leaving as emmett came in and
while emmett was there another cousin
stood at the door
and the cousin who stood at the door
said that never happened
other people who were around at the time
said he wasn't even in the store long
enough for any of that to have happened
so what we have here is the testimony of
a woman at trial
a month after the event and a belief on
the part of many people that this story
was enhanced
to justify if you can justify
what was done to this kid that he had
crossed the line
of southern you know custom
at the time and that he deserved to be
punished that was the story that they
had
fed in the community there and the story
that um
from what i understand the jurors had
heard long before the trial ever
occurred
in 1955 when he was killed you say that
in tallahatchie county there were 11 000
whites and 19 000 blacks right
what was what were the rights of blacks
in that year in that state
mississippi there was not a single black
person who was registered to vote and i
think that
pretty much says everything at this time
and again this is a year after the
initial decision in brown versus board
of education and just
a couple of months after the
implementation order that the supreme
court had handed down
that that school desegregation should
proceed with all deliberate speed
while that didn't change everything
immediately uh
by way of law in this country or at
least as a practical matter i mean the
schools took a long time as we know to
uh
to start desegregating it activated
whites in the south who were terribly
afraid
that their way of life was going to
change and
they set out systematically to enforce
the old way of the south and that
enforcement gained official sanctions so
people were intimidated
they were um they were intimidated you
know when they tried to register to vote
and obviously it was effective as you
see in tallahassee county
people were not only subject to economic
reprisal and it was it was severe
i mean you had white citizens councils
throughout mississippi
who i heard described as the kkk and
business suits
who would publish lists of of registered
voters and if there were blacks
who had attempted to register they were
fired from their jobs
their home mortgages were were
foreclosed on and
they were not allowed to buy seed for
planting if they were farmers
they could not get low loans for
equipment
they were driven out of business and
there was no forgiveness even
after they would remove their names from
the voter rolls
they still were not allowed to uh to
have a livelihood so it was a horrible
state
at that point but beyond the economic
reprisals people were actually murdered
for attempting to exercise their rights
just before emmett arrived in
mississippi
um reverend george lee in nearby
belzoni was murdered he was an naacp
leader
in the state he was murdered for
attempting to register
people to vote there was a major
cover-up of his murder and
you know the sheriff said well it wasn't
a shotgun blast as everybody had
had determined but it was in fact a car
accident he was he was shot
as he was driving down the highway and
even though the lead
uh pellets were retrieved the the
sheriff
denied that that ever happened another
person lamar smith was murdered
in nearby brookhaven
uh just two weeks before emmitt arrived
in mississippi
he was trying to pass out leaflets in
the town square
in broad daylight on a saturday
afternoon
he was approached by several white
citizens who
who shot him in front of so many
witnesses who never saw a thing
so this was the the condition of life
for for blacks in mississippi
there were rights but you could not
exercise your rights
so after he was in the store at bryant's
what happened then what time of day was
that this was in the evening this was um
at the beginning of cotton picking
season and uh
and he was just visiting there for a
week he was visiting yeah and
you know he was having a lot of fun this
was several days after he had arrived in
mississippi
and a group of the kids went into went
uptown as they called it
to buy some treats that's what they did
at the end of the day
after picking cotton all day they had
supper and
in the early evening they would drive up
town and
just sort of hang out so this was about
six or seven in the evening
what happened next well they went into
the store as i mentioned one at a time
basically and uh he made his purchase
and left
as people have recounted and um
there was the whistle and at some point
somebody said
you know that they were going to get in
trouble because of that because it
looked like the woman
carolyn bryant was offended so they
jumped in the car and drove away
as they were driving uh there's a very
dramatic scene that
that people had described to to mother
mobley of
a light appearing in in behind them uh
headlights from a car they thought they
were being chased
and they all ran through the cotton
fields they stopped the car and ran
through the cotton fields to hide and as
it turned out it was just a car
passing so within a few days of that
nothing had happened
and everybody felt that this whole thing
would pass there was no
problem and that's when roy bryant and
j.w milam came to
uh to the house of image relatives and
and drag them out where'd they take them
that is um is is one of the
the questions that hasn't fully been
answered they described a circuitous
route through the
roy bryant and j.w milam described the
route that they
they took him on through the back roads
of of the mississippi delta
there is at least a report by several
witnesses
that they stopped in a nearby county
sunflower county
at a plantation that was managed by one
of
milam's brothers leslie milam there were
witnesses who actually testified at
trial black witnesses
who testified at trial that they saw
emmett in the back of a pickup truck
with two
black men sitting there holding him and
several white men
in the cab they saw the truck later
parked
at a shed on this plantation they saw
jw milam coming out periodically with a
gun strapped to his
his uh waist and uh taking water
they heard beating inside the uh the
shed and they heard
moans from what what they
believe was was emmett and later they
saw the truck
pull closer to the shed put something in
there
and cover the back with a tarp and
everyone believed that was in its body
where'd they take him they took him to
the tallahatchie river where he was
dumped
now the the version of the story that
that um uh roy bryant and jw milam told
to
look magazine was that that emmett was
defiant
that they had just roughed him up a
little bit to teach him a lesson
but that he was defined up to the point
of standing at the edge of the
tallahatchie river
and uh in effect dared them to
to kill him and that would have been
impossible as you see the condition of
his body
he was so savagely beaten that he likely
couldn't have even stood at that point
and
he very likely was already dead when he
was carried to the uh
to the river they tied a gin fan
around his neck with barb wire how heavy
is a gin fan
uh about 75 pounds there were wide
reports on the weight of it 75 to 150
pounds but
it was about 75 pounds according to most
accounts and they rolled it into the
river and dragged his body there
and his body was discovered uh only a
few days later
when another teenager was out in the
river fishing
and one of emmett's legs had risen to
the top
and was was seen and that's how he was
discovered
when they discovered the body what
happened then well he was
uh pulled ashore and
he was not recognizable except for a
ring
that he wore on his uh the middle finger
of his left hand
and as it turned out that was a ring
that his mother had given to him
just before he left for mississippi it
was a ring that had been left by his
father
a soldier in europe during world war ii
and she had given it to him he had tried
it on for
you know off and on for many years
before that it never really fit it was
kind of a loose fit even then but he
wanted to wear it
he wanted to show it off to his his
friends and cousins in mississippi
and uh brag about his father who had
been a soldier
as it turns out he allowed one of his
cousins
to wear that ring while they were
playing around in the fields
and his cousin was able to help identify
him through
the ring before we move on
there is a story about his father that
mother mobley found out later his father
you got a picture of him in here louis
till
right uh and what was the story and when
did she find it out
the story was that at when emmett was
about four
his father was uh the bottom picture
he's the bottom picture and i don't know
if you can get close in you can see the
ring on his finger
there he's in italy at the time and i
believe this is 1943 or 44.
um jimmy's father
louis till was killed during the war as
his mother uh believed as as mamie till
mobley believed
uh she got noticed of that when emmett
was was four
but as it turns out he was executed
after the war and she had tried over the
course of many years to find out what
had happened what she received was a
notice from the
military that the spousal allotment
was being terminated it actually was an
allotment for emmett
and she never really knew what
the cause was except that the language
in the letter
included the words willful misconduct
it was only after the murder trial
that the cause was publicized
and she discovered then that
lewis till was accused of murder rape
and murder in
italy and that he was executed the
execution order was signed by
general dwight david eisenhower and
it was a curious thing to her because
after that i mean it came as a shock to
her
and it came after the murder trial
before the grand jury was to be convened
to
to consider a kidnapping charge which
was
separate from the murder and she
believed always that this was a
deliberate attempt to influence the
grand jury
which didn't hand down an indictment as
it turns out
the uh reporters who uh covered that
story the revelation about louis till
admitted that they got the information
they got which they couldn't have
uh discovered from the the the
department of defense
they got that through the help of
senator james eastland of mississippi at
the time who was a
staunch segregationist and one of the
leaders
in the movement to establish the white
citizens councils in
mississippi and the effort to resist the
enforcement of
brown versus board of education so she
always believed that that was a
deliberate attempt to
change the the course of events as it
turns out
mother mobley talked to a number of of
louis till's army buddies after this
she talked to her own brother-in-law she
later married and her brother-in-law had
also served in
europe uh during the war and it seemed
that this was a common thing that
occurred
among blacks in the military who were
marched out
at you know two in the morning or so and
told to line up and identified by
women in europe as men they had had
relations with
or men they were accusing of of
something and there's a book that's
going to be coming out soon that deals
with this
that during the course of the war there
were many more
black soldiers than whites who were
accused of such crimes
even when they were unfounded and
court-martialed and executed so we don't
know what really happened in this case
i want to come back to the situation
with them until in just a second
again this was 1955. a couple of quick
things um
the civil rights bill of 57 end of 60
and of 64
were what and how much did
this incident have to do with moving the
civil rights bill of 57 along well
primarily the the civil rights bill of
57 um
during the course of the congressional
hearings there was testimony about
emmett till the trial
and the the lack of justice in in the
case
and there are many who believe that that
was influential in
getting that first civil rights bill
through
and as a result the office of the
assistant attorney general for civil
rights was established and the us
commission on civil rights was
established among other things
so there was um probably the most
tangible uh effect
of uh of this uh this this event um
the later civil rights acts really were
by and large a result of the civil
rights
movement starting with brown versus
board of education
and the the movement that was energized
as a result of of a series of events
really brown certainly
told us all that that that progress
could be made
rosa parks and the the montgomery bus
boycott that lasted for more than a year
helped to encourage people to to
demonstrate to participate in the
movement and they were in fact as
many people have said energized by what
they saw during the course of events uh
it uh with emmett's murder and the
the trial and the the the courage that
so many people showed
as a result of of uh you know coming
forward to testify
the sequence so 54 was brown 55 was this
murder right and then how about the
march to selma the birmingham bombing
and uh those were all during the 60s
rosa park happened when
and also in 55 it uh the the murder of
emmett till occurred in august of
uh 55 august 28th the trial was in late
september
and uh the montgomery bus boycott
started in effect
in december of 55. and again before we
return to the story
your background where did you you say
grew up in chicago
how many kids in the family there are
two of us my sister
uh who's a children's book writer and an
illustrator
and your mother did what for a living
she was uh well she was in show business
many years ago she was a dancer but
while we were coming up she was she was
a secretary did you ever know your dad
no and you went where to school
well we lived in chicago for the most
part so i went to school
through grade school in chicago we also
lived in los angeles
uh so i attended school there and then
we moved to new york
where i attended high school and how
about college where'd you go what'd you
study college we moved back to illinois
so i studied
at the university of illinois i earned
my bachelor's and my master's degrees in
journalism there
and then i became a journalist i was
writing for ebony magazine for
years and transferred to washington i
was washington editor
and then took leave to to attend
georgetown to study law
did you get your law degree yes i did
are you practicing law i'm not
practicing now
immediately after law school i thought
actually i was going to
continue writing my intention was to
return to the washington bureau
of ebony and to write with the
substantive foundation
but i was returned to chicago i went on
corporate side for the company and i was
in-house counsel for about 13 years and
then returned to writing after that
how big is the johnson publishing
operation now with ebony
well ebony is probably the largest
circulation black magazine in the
country
it is actually it's got uh 1.8 million
paid circulation and total readership of
about 11 million
and jet magazine is roughly a million
and a multiple of about five times for a
pass along so
the magazines reach a good number of
people who runs it now
uh well john h johnson is the founder
the
publisher and the uh ceo the um
chairman of the board his daughter linda
johnson rice is the ceo now
and this book was finished when what
date
it was finished in april of 2003
and it was published in october and when
did again did she die
she died in january of that year january
2000 so she never saw the publication
she never saw the actual book
she saw the progress it would be that we
were making though and she took great
joy in that and where do you get that
the name mother mobley
well partly because she
she inspires that in you when when you
when you beat her so many people
looked upon her as a mother you know she
never had another
biological child but she embraced so
many children during the course of the
remaining years that she had
after emmett's murder she was a
schoolteacher for 23 years she was an
active church member
during that entire period and she
formed the emmett till players during
the course of of her
her years as a teacher the emmett till
players
were groups of students who
she taught speeches by dr martin luther
king jr too and so she wanted to teach
them a sense of history she wanted to
teach them the connection to emmett till
and all these students hundreds of
students she was able to reach and touch
looked upon her
as a mother figure she became a church
mother it's a rank in the church
where you know you reach a certain level
where you can influence
and guide other women in the church so
she was proud of the fact that she'd
become a church mother so it's also an
official title
that she carried this is a picture of
her hand at the
civil rights museum memorial civil
rights memorial in montgomery
at the headquarters of the southern
poverty law center she was there for the
dedication
and um she is part of the memorial
it's a a myelin sculpture black granite
same woman that did the vietnam the
vietnam memorial uh there's a there's a
table uh with
a fountain that flows over the table and
it's it's a continuum of all the
or many of the martyrs of the civil
rights movement and emmett till's name
is
uh engraved there so that was a picture
of her actually touching
his name and it was quite a moving
experience for her
and she was born where she was born in
uh
mississippi uh not far from where this
occurred in hazelhurst and when did she
leave there
she left there when she was two years
old to chicago
her family moved to chicago and as was
the case with so many
families moving out of mississippi uh
her mother and she left first her father
stayed on to just tie up some business
uh
farming uh accounting for the the
sharecropping
crops that they had processed so they
left in the early fall
he left in uh in december and uh they
they settled near chicago in argo who's
papa mose
papa moes is um emmett's great uncle
and the person he was staying with in
money mississippi
papa moes is quite a hero in this story
he was the person who tried to stand his
ground
when these two men came in with guns at
two o'clock in the morning and took
emmett away
he later stayed on to testify
at the trial and had the
courage to stand in a courtroom in the
mississippi delta
in 1955 and point
to two white men and accuse them of a
crime nobody had ever heard of that
happening
in mississippi and he did it at great
risk to his life
and is considered one of the the many
unsung heroes of the civil rights
movement because of that so many people
saw the image you just showed and were
encouraged by it they were inspired by
it
that bravery that courage that he showed
in in doing that
um helped so many other people to uh
you know to gain the courage they needed
to to do sometimes the most simple
things i mean
people talk about the stand that rosa
parks took as mother mobley would say um
she took a stand by keeping her seat so
many people say that such a simple act
but it was a simple act of great courage
great bravery because at the time you
risked your life in taking that kind of
stand i don't think enough people
understand that now
because we're in the courtroom for the
moment just a couple of things uh
you point out in the book that there
were 22 seats for white reporters and
four for black reporters initially
initially why
what was that about why so few for black
reporters well the
the people didn't understand that at the
time
the sheriff of the county had all the
power in the county
and the sheriff at this time h c strider
was uh a horrible racist um
you know he made no bones about that and
he was determined that during the course
of this
this huge media event what what david
halberstam would call later
the the first big media event of the
civil rights movement
strider was determined that black and
white reporters were not going to
co-mingle he was going to enforce
segregation
in his courtroom and he considered it to
be his courtroom even though the judge
was presiding
he was in charge of every institution in
that that community
and so he had set aside four seats for
black reporters off to the side
as it turned out this the event of the
trial
gained so much notoriety that there was
something like 100
news reporters and photographers who had
come down to
sumner mississippi where the the trial
was held
and it was difficult to accommodate this
this great number
there wound up being about 12 black
reporters and photographers who came and
so they
wound up fashioning a table uh for the
black reporters to uh to be seated at
and
it was a quite a rough table as mother
mobley described it
it was it was so rough that she tore her
skirt
uh on the splinters as she tried to
scoot her seat up to it
this was not just the jim crow table for
the reporters as it turned out
but it was the table where some of the
witnesses like mother mobley
were seated and in fact a u.s
congressman
people white people in mississippi were
astounded
when congressman charles diggs from
detroit showed up to observe the trial
and they didn't believe at the time that
there was any such thing as
a as a black congressman in fact one
sheriff's deputy uh remarked and this
these are his words that were reported
a [ __ ] congressman it it's not
possible it's not even
legal finally he was able to convince
him that he was a congressman and he
also was seated
at the jim crow table in this picture
also is simeon booker here with the
glasses i believe who was
jet magazine and right here is uh amy
too
at that time how was she then she was
33.
go back to the riverside where they find
his body they pick who picks him up by
the way and
moves him to the funeral home sheriff
strider was there
one of his deputies was there they
brought a black undertaker
there to handle the body and papa mose
was summoned to
um to identify him because the word
obviously it was out that this kid was
missing so the first call went to him
and he identified the body and then
sheriff strider ordered that the body be
buried immediately that day
what happened mother mobley insisted
when she got news that they were
preparing to bury emmett in mississippi
she insisted that he be returned to her
in chicago
and papa moe's worked with one of
mother mobley's cousins crosby smith
to make sure that he was brought back to
chicago and crosby smith
who is one of the her closest cousins um
vowed that he would bring him it back if
he had to drive a truck
and pack him in ice and and and drive
him himself but they were able to get
the body released
as i mentioned it was released under
seal and orders not to open the box
and her cousin crosby rode the train
back within its body the city of new
orleans train
which brought him back on on friday
september 2nd
and she was there at the uh train
station
to to greet the body one of the the
pictures you showed earlier was
uh her reaction to the the box
that was unloaded uh there and uh
you know at this point it all became so
real to her and as she described
that box i mean it was it was huge and
she's such a little woman
she's barely five feet tall
but she nearly collapsed at that that
moment and there behind her
is the man she would later marry gene
mobley who was there to comfort her
throughout
and the two ministers who uh who helped
her through
the uh the the grieving and the the
funeral married to gene mobley for
with him at least 42 years i don't know
that long
when did the public first hear about
this and
how much did the black press what kind
of role the black
press play the chicago defender and jet
magazine and things like that in this
story
well the chicago defender had been
covering um
horrible crimes like this for some time
uh it was probably one of the few places
where you could
actually see coverage of of lynchings
you know the black press was was uh
determined to carry pictures
the atlanta daily world the chicago
defender all of the
the black newspapers carried these
stories so
the reporters were used to covering this
kind of story jet magazine
also uh did its part in um in in
covering uh
what the the crimes against uh against
blacks
so a number of black newspapers and jet
magazine sent reporters down
to to sumner to cover the trial
in fact the jet magazine and ebony sent
a team of reporters and so did the
defender the defender had several
additions including a tri-state defender
that was published out of memphis
did you say that jet magazine sent a
black reporter and a white photographer
yes
why was that well the publisher uh john
h johnson
believed that a white photographer would
be able to get into places that a black
photographer would and he was right
about that i mean
the the black reporters were there as
you saw there were restrictions
on their movement in the courtroom but
there were also restrictions on their
movement in the larger community
um the one of the incredible stories
that came out of this story
was how black reporters were determined
to move
beyond the boundaries that had been set
for them
they were there to cover a story but
they were also black people
who knew what we all were confronting
at that time in that place and there was
a problem that the investigation of this
crime ran into
a number of witnesses were disclosed
in the black community but they had not
been brought forward
the prosecution had no resources with
which to
investigate the crime and to carry it
forward so close to the time of trial
there were it looked like there were
only be two witnesses for the
prosecution
papa moe's who could testify and
identify
the uh the people who had come into his
home so he could testify to the
kidnapping
and his son simeone who was 12 at the
time
they were going to bring him in to
establish that the ring
identified emmett's body and that was it
but there were people who
had seen various aspects of this crime
unfolding as i mentioned
uh people who had identified roy bryant
and j.w milam
at the sheraton plantation in sunflower
county
had seen emmett in the back of a truck
had heard the beating
there were people out there who had
these stories to tell and
the issue at the time was to bring them
forward to make sure that they testify
and the black reporters participated in
that search at the time
there were many people who worked in the
cotton fields in the the mississippi
delta and they of course didn't trust
white people so to have a sheriff's
deputy come out into the field
and ask them to come forward with
something that terrified them
and they wouldn't have come uh thinking
that they would be in great payroll
themselves so the black reporters helped
to bring them out the trial was held in
what city in sumner
that in tallahassee county was what kind
of a court was it county state
it was the the county court the jury how
many
people on the jury there were 12 white
men
were women allowed to sit in the jury
then not at that time no and 12
white men the judge was
a white man yes all the principals in
this case were white the judge
the prosecutors and the defense
attorneys obviously um
it's interesting there were five lawyers
practicing in
uh tallahatchie county during this time
and all five of them
uh volunteered to work for the defense
that's one of the defense attorneys uh
the defense attorney's on the right of
your screen there and then jw kellum
callum i mean not kelm but milam is in
the middle yes and bryant is on the
left-hand side right
the trial lasted how long it lasted four
days
how long were those days well
some of them were shorter because you
know on the what was to be the first day
of trial after the jury was selected
there was a postponement because word
had reached the judge that
there was a belief there were some
witnesses out there who could come
forward and offer
a very helpful testimony so they
postponed until the next day that was a
short day
generally it was from about nine in the
morning until
late afternoon the temperature very hot
apparently the temperature was in the
90s
outside but as mother mobley described
in the court it felt like 118 degrees
and even hotter when you consider the
tension the terrible tension that
existed in that
dead courtroom were there any live
microphones in the room or television or
film no um there are pictures that i've
seen
published of different parts of the
interior but the judge had ordered early
on that
there would be no more photography after
the initial stages of jury selection
there would be no more photography in
the courtroom during the proceeding
the picture you saw of of mo's wright um
pointing out
the uh the murderers in the in the case
it was a picture that was taken secretly
by one of the black photographers ernest
withers who was quite
a hero throughout the the civil rights
movement himself covering many
many important stories at great risk to
his own life he was there at the
the angle you see there is from the the
jim crow table
and that's a cropped picture but when
you see the full
image you can see that he's shooting
between some people
at the table and he just sort of pops
off a shot
instantly at that precise moment and to
show you how important that photo was
a one of the wire services
apparently saw him do that and
uh bought the film right out of his
camera and there's a lot of details
uh that we're not gonna have time to go
to into in the trial but the
jury met for how long after this trial
was over just a little more than an hour
67 minutes
and uh during that the period of 67
minutes they took a
a coke break because they were asked to
make it look good
you said that cokes could not be bought
by blacks right
why the vendors who moved in and out of
the courtroom would not sell to blacks
why because uh they were discriminating
against blacks it was a
horrible period of race hatred and and
so uh mother mobley made the mistake of
trying to buy something at one point she
was insulted as a result
now uh when the verdict was announced
what was it and what happened the
verdict was
not guilty but even before that as as
mother mobley had recalled um
when the the jury was sent out to
deliberate
she looked around the courtroom she
heard the closing arguments
she was quite moved by what the
prosecution had
had put out there but she looked around
and she saw
the expressions on the faces of the
black people in particular
who were standing around at the rear of
this packed courtroom
and she realized then that they were
starting to move out of the courtroom
because they didn't want to be around
when the inevitable verdict came in
she knew that it was going to be not
guilty and she turned to congressman
diggs and said
i think it's time for us to go and she
remembers that the congressman said well
you want to leave now you don't want to
hear the verdict she said
i don't think this is a verdict we want
to be around to hear
and all of the black principals who came
down for the trial were staying in
nearby
mound bayou which was an all-black town
they all got in the cars and and left to
to return to mount bayou
and just before they hit it was about an
hour away an hour's drive
um just at the time they were
approaching mountain bio she said she
heard the report on the radio
and it sounded like the fourth of july
because it was such a
celebration among the whites in town
that
these two men were acquitted this is
only because of time but i want to jump
totally out of context in this story
to this quote it's by roy wilkins
former head of the naacp you're trying
to capitalize on the death of your son
on quote page 207
that that tells a whole story that you
actually i'm
interested why she went into all this
story about what happened to her
afterwards and
the whole issue of money but again i'll
read it you're trying to capitalize on
the death of your son what's that about
well uh she went out on a speaking tour
immediately after the trial um this was
a period of a great financial
strain for the civil rights movement um
the naacp had spent
all of its resources human resources and
money on the brown decision there were
several cases that were decided with
brown they had been uh
building these cases for 15 years this
uh
naacp was was strapped at the time and
as a result of the speaking tour they
were able to raise uh
quite a bit of money and and we saw this
in reports that other newspapers had put
out
thousands and thousands of dollars were
raised at these rallies
where she attended um they negotiated uh
a deal where she was to receive i guess
100 150 dollars per speaking engagement
it was quite a bit of money there's no
question about
it there was at one point the proposal
that she do a tour out
west in california and by this time
there were a number of people as i
learned who were
who were representing her who were
negotiating for her she had struck a
deal with with roy wilkins she had
met him and was engaged by him there was
no question about that
but then at a certain point there were
other people representing her and i
don't know that they were representing
her best interest
i even read reports about this uh from
the time that
there were people who were trying to
negotiate i guess for more money they
had convinced her that
if she did the tour she would not have
enough money to pay all of her own
expenses and she needed to to ask for
more money
so with her authorization i guess they
pressed for that and
i guess the dispute developed and at a
certain point
roy wilkins called her himself and uh
and that's when he made that comment
that she recalled and it was quite
hurtful
to her i mean it broke her heart for a
couple of reasons
one because she was not trying to pursue
the money issue herself
but other people were pursuing it on her
behalf she offered to
forget about the money which leads to
the second reason it was so hurtful to
her at this time she was still grieving
the loss of her son
it was a terribly painful experience one
that you know we can't even imagine
and at a certain point when you're
grieving people kind of expect that
you're going to move on
so she couldn't really talk to friends
and family after a certain point but in
making these these public addresses that
she made speaking of crowds of up to 10
000 people at a time she was able to
continue to grieve
it was cathartic for her and she knew
now that that was going to be cut off
and that hurt her deeply
because she had to contain all of it and
as you uh see in the book
at a certain point after this she
reached the brink of considering suicide
did she make a lot of money off this not
that i
know of she never uh described a great
deal of money that she made and other
people who
knew about her at the time uh couldn't
see a lot of money
that she was making of course a hundred
150 of speech was
was quite a bit of money at that time
but she left her job
and she had other expenses she was also
providing for her father who would
accompany her so
i don't know that she netted a great
deal of money how long did it take you
all to talk this out
we talked for the six months that she
was uh
that she was around after we met uh
starting in june
or she on dialysis then she was on
dialysis three times a week
it's a great strain on her um and she
she still was trying to maintain an
active uh speaking
uh you know uh speaking engagements um
so uh we we fit it in whenever we could
and at a certain point we're talking
three or four days a week
formally and in between those sessions
so
quite quite a few hours during the
course she was a beautiful person
she uh she had the most incredible aura
uh that surrounded her that you
you you saw immediately when you met her
and she was um
she was so full of love uh that was one
of the most incredible things that you
noticed when you first met her
she had no bitterness at all it was one
of the most interesting things that i
saw was that
she was opposed to capital punishment
she never wanted the murderers of her
son to be executed she only wanted them
to be sorry for what they had done
she only wanted the state of mississippi
to express its apology as well so those
are the things that were striking about
her
when did she die and under what
circumstances she
she died in january 2003 of a massive
heart attack she was preparing to go to
atlanta
for speaking engagement and she died the
day before she was to leave
what impact did this whole thing have on
you well certainly as i mentioned um
the story of emmett till has been with
me most of my life
so i thought it was an incredible
experience to have the chance to just
meet emmett till's mother but then to
have the chance to help her tell her
story was was irresistible
she mentioned as a as i told you she
mentioned that she wanted to do a book
and it took me all of two seconds to
decide that i wanted to help her with it
and we worked that out immediately to
have had a hand in in telling the story
i think is is is quite a unique
experience i was too young to take part
in the civil rights movement but now i
feel that i have participated
in in telling this story you know it's
you can't really understand where we are
now without knowing something of the
history
of this country in the latter part of
the 20th century and you can't
understand that story without knowing
the civil rights
movement and you really don't fully
appreciate the civil rights movement
without knowing the emmett till story
so now i understand that and it's been
quite a moving experience for me
and one that helped me to renew my own
personal commitment
this is a woman who who lived a
committed life she lived on purpose
every moment of her life following the
son of of her following the
the murder of her son and she inspired
that and so many other people who were
touched by her and i certainly was one
of those people
and this photograph on the cover of the
book
how old was he and where was this taking
you know he was 13 years old at the time
that photo was taken
and that was taken at their last
christmas celebration together
she for some reason was moved to um
to make that christmas the most special
one ever not knowing that it would be
their last one together so
she spent an awful lot of money on gifts
and in a big dinner
and then she decided she wanted to
memorialize it by having pictures made
she had no
pictures made of him when when he was
growing up
after his childhood and he was 13 at
that time
so she decided to have pictures made
that's one of the famous shots of
of him and her together the other one
you showed of him leaning on the
television was shot at that time as well
and there's another famous shot of him
with a wide brim hat on that was a
christmas gift that he had received at
the time so she was quite proud of that
that christmas celebration and wanted to
memorialize it not knowing that those
would be the last photographs
ever taken of him alive they were also
posted
on his casket so as people filed by
they saw his body but they saw what what
he had been like before he was
brutalized
christopher benson has been our guest
and the story
told to him by mamie till mobley cover
the book again
death of innocence thank you very much
for joining us it's been my pleasure